they soared like a plastic meteor
straight into the Sun and had a
company-wide meltdown here's why Funko
dumped 30 million dollars of toys in a
landfill and where they're going next
funko's humble beginnings date back to
1998 when toy Enthusiast Mike Becker
started the business from his home for
seven years a company experienced modest
success in selling bobbleheads including
characters such as the big boy mascots
the Cheerios honeybee Popeye and others
in 2005 fellow toy Enthusiast Brian
Mariotti recognize funko's potential and
bought the company from Becca shortly
after Mariachi pivoted slightly away
from bobbleheads with a new line of
nostalgic themed figurines called
Fantastic Plastic soon Funko began
expanding its licensing into movies
television and video games and
showcasing their products nationwide at
different conventions I think we knew
what great then and there that we had
something on our hands by 2011 Funko
would hit its stride with a new line of
products that would put the company on a
fast track to becoming a global
phenomenon Q Funko Pop funko's Pop vinyl
line popped up on the scene as early as
2010 when Brian marietti debuted the
Prototype at the 2010 San Diego
Comic-Con originally named Funko Force
2.0 the line featured characters from
the DC Universe including Green Lantern
bad girl and two versions of Batman one
year later with some slight design
adjustments they were introduced to the
New York toy Ferris Funko Pops Funko Pop
stood out with their large Square heads
disproportionately small bodies round
pupilus eyes and traditionally no mouth
although certain variants included this
feature despite their toy like
appearance Funko Pops driving consumers
for adults rather than children unlike
traditional action figures or bobble
heads Funko Pop was the first of its
kind to offer something new leaving no
franchise and tapped he's like a friend
that'll never leave you because you
turned into a zombie the popliner since
expanded to include other merchandise
such as apparel plushies and keychains
as time progressed the Funko company as
a whole only continued to evolve a pop
culture company like Funko is built on
licensing agreements which permit Funko
to use the licenser's intellectual
property since the company's Inception
is licenses have grown to include more
than 1 000 different properties from
some of the biggest names in pop culture
and entertainment these properties range
from movies TV and video games to anime
Sports and music allowing Funko to
produce thousands of characters if not
tens of thousands in multiple variants
although franchises such as Star Wars
and Harry Potter are some of their best
selling products Brian mariati Assurance
license Global that Funko wasn't
interested in only producing figures
that made the most money he said we're
going to drive development based on the
characters that mean the most to us we
want to represent the brands as best as
we can and that doesn't mean cherry
picking the main characters and not
doing the tertiary characters is it
stupid to live by a code to have honor
big words for a little man yeah in an
era of sequel and remakes and the luxury
of built-in fandoms it seems only
natural that Funko could stand the test
of time Funko Stark went public on
November 2nd 2017 setting its IPO at 12
per share with hopes to raise upwards of
125 million dollars their first day
return made headlines but not for the
reasons one would want despite pricing
lower than expected Bunko shares dropped
41.1 percent closing at Amiga 7.07 their
stock launch was dubbed to the worst
first day return for an IPO in 17 years
but this bump in the road wasn't enough
to deter the company why America
explained to geek wire I told our
employees no matter what happens whether
the stock goes up or the stock goes down
it's kind of irrelevant because we
haven't changed anything that we said we
are going to do in the future or what we
are currently doing now less than a year
later Funko stock resurged by exceeding
its original 12 pricing now that's a pop
business
this was on the rise in addition to
selling straight to the consumer Funko
expanded to Big Box retailers as well as
smaller local shops Nationwide in 2019
Funko opened its biggest storefront in
Los Angeles and their press release
Funko promised the 40 000 square foot
Hollywood location will be brimming with
highly shareable social media moments
including life-size Funko statues and
immersive sets inspired by some of the
biggest pop culture fandoms
it's one billion dollars in sales in
2021 a 58 increase from the year before
but the company wasn't the only thing
increasing in value individual pop
figures started reselling at an all-time
high retail prices typically range from
10 to 15 but if you are lucky enough to
get your hands on certain exclusives or
limited edition stock it could be worth
upwards of 25
000 and in fact Funko Pops value
skyrocketers so most has some even
resorted to thievery most notably a New
York City man accidentally knocked an
elderly woman unconscious or fleeing a
Barnes and Noble with 35 worth of Funko
Pops you know they're obsessed it's a
great business you got here at this
point many considered their collections
as Investments according to NASDAQ the
top three most valuable Funko Pops in
2022 included Alex from A Clockwork
Orange Freddy Funko as Venom and
metallic Stan Lee and in May 2022 the
largest resale in Funko history took
place in Glendale California where a man
purchased a rare gold Willy Wonka set
accompanied by a golden ticket for one
hundred thousand dollars as far as Funko
Pop consumers go there are two types you
make of the majority of Funko sales
there are the dedicated collectors who
never miss a release and display their
vast array of prized possessions for all
to see and the other is a casual buyer
who only picks up specific Funko Pop
characters from their favorite
franchises no matter which category a
consumer falls under you're no more or
less part of the Funko Community the
online community expands further outside
the company but collectors posting their
own content online centered around Funko
YouTube creators engage with fellow fans
by showcasing their collections product
unboxings and keeping subscribers up to
date on Funko news Funko Pop groups sell
trade and share on Facebook but nothing
compares to the magic felt when hundreds
of Funko Fanatics Gather in person at
conventions and events debuting
exclusive lines and interacting with the
community has enabled Funko to carve out
a significant space at conventions such
as Comic-Con Fan Expo Star Wars
celebration and E3
[Applause]
I can't although Funko has gained a
loyal following fans aren't afraid to
speak up against unfavorable choices
made by the company take for example
funko's Venture into nfts in 2021 Funko
announced this entry into the nft market
and was met with a poor response as one
Reddit user wrote they've shown they
don't really understand the nft market
and they've just seen it as an
opportunity to increase the bottom line
dramatically more criticism followed
after Funko released to Bob Ross nft
going against the artist's wishes of
wanting to avoid using his likeness for
profit nft scandals didn't mark the end
of funko's controversies fans were
surprised when Funko released a dead
Laura Palmer figure from Twin Peaks a
change.org petition was even created to
ban the character more recently Funko
came under Fire for supposedly
whitewashing the character Prince Naveen
from The Princess and the Frog the
company Twitter account deleted the
original image and released a follow-up
statement which said our previous post
showed an image of the navine Funko Pop
That is not true to the product which is
accurately shown here still this
wouldn't be the company's first offense
in this area with similar accusations
leveled at it in the past these
controversies combined have been enough
to cause some distrust in the company
what was once considered a key selling
point for Funko became its greatest flaw
as far as Funko is concerns the company
is in the business of creating something
for everyone not only are there
thousands of characters to choose from
but there's also a long list of variants
for each character Chase variants offer
an alternative version of a character
including anything from an outfit change
to a glow-in-the-dark appearance flocked
variants replace a vinyl texture with a
soft fuzzy one Diamond variants add a
shimmer of glitter to characters the
list continues with chrome metallic and
black light variants comedian and
television host Conan O'Brien had 34
variants alone yeah otherwise known as
Conan without coffee and makeup perhaps
it became too much when a funko's third
quarter report for 2022 was released the
company revealed that there wasn't issue
involving a subplus and inventory to
make matters worse chains were delaying
or canceling orders overall the third
quarter of 2022 reported a 39 decline in
net income from the previous year in an
attempt to push out more Supply more and
more Funko products began popping up in
discount stores and hitting clearance
shelves still the worst was Yet to Come
funko's fourth quarter report for 2022
proved just how detrimental the damage
had become Ryan Mariotti revealed in a
conference call a combination of macro
factors and funko-specific issues have
disrupted our financial and operating
performance to an unacceptable degree
one of these factors was the exponential
cost of housing excess inventory part of
the company's solution made shocking
headlines since attempting to sell off
the inventory at a discounted price
wasn't cutting it Funko instead made the
decision to dump at least 30 million
dollars worth of products into a
landfill so where are we now
struck out the way to the dump
[Music]
between the waste environmental concerns
and in consideration with regards to
this decision fans of Funko were
disappointed to say the least one Reddit
user said this is most likely just
another example of corporate greed they
would rather throw unsold merchandise
away than donate it or give it away but
it's bad press enough to tank the
company for good while all of this was
going on Funko stock continued to drop
after a drastic fall following 2022's
third quarter earnings NASDAQ reported
that the stock dropped a whopping 59.3
percent funko's downfall became a
numbers game with the company on the
losing end it's extra surprising too
given that Funko reported better than
expected Revenue in the latest quarter
comparing 2021 and 2022's fourth quarter
reports net sales decreased by one
percent while Net's income decreased by
a staggering 368 however the company
kept up an optimistic front writing in
the report Funko is highly focused on
identifying and addressing opportunities
for improvement however these
initiatives will take several quarters
in some cases and as a result we expect
sequential improvements throughout the
year as our initiatives take hold what
exactly does all this mean for the
future of Funko many factors come into
play when analyzing what went wrong
between 2021's record-breaking profits
and the shortcomings of the second half
of 2022 when comparing Funko to other
Collectibles that eventually faded Into
Obscurity such as Beanie Babies the
pattern becomes more clear commonality
and similarity are slowly hurting
funko's collectible brand that's Funko
try cicada to everyone by creating Funko
Pops for everything under the pop
culture Sun the only value comes from
consumers buying at retail price drawing
the height of the covert pandemic people
clung to entertainment and hobbies for
Comfort Funko products weren't exactly
new but their Vitality Drew in an
excited new crowd however as time went
on that excitement diminished slightly
of course this doesn't mean no one is
buying Funko products there was still a
29 increase in net sales for the full
fiscal year of 2022 compared to 2021 so
if Funko can sort out its supply issues
and bring a new level of excitement back
to the collector Community there could
still be hope for the future
[Music]
foreign